[Music]
grass is something we take for granted
we walk all over it lay on it
and sometimes mow it down
most of us don't give it much thought
few of us appreciated the way that dan
harvey and heather aykroyd do
i think we create these pieces partly
because we just love actually the magic
of seeing them in print and and come to
life and grow the british artists blur
the lines between science nature and art
by manipulating the nature processes
that fuel life itself
to create their canvases
you're actually imbuing it with this
energy and creating with with life
they're almost dayglow images when you
first see them they're very very
beautiful
[Music]
if you actually look at what's happened
in the last 25 years if you look at
what's happened in the last five years
mega flooding scenario severe weather
events are happening time and time and
time again and increasingly more
frequently and the science is very very
clear and unambiguous about this our
work is very much embraced around
processes of change around nature around
biodiversity loss around climate change
from the very first time that dan and i
started to work together it was you know
it was within our sight it's not
necessarily a direct action or activism
sometimes pieces are very very poetic
[Music]
we maybe only do one
one or two photosynthesis works a year i
i think what's interesting is that we're
we're not working with lawn or with sod
or with tough we work with with the seed
dan and heather germinate their seeds
for about two weeks
when ready they're rubbed onto the
canvas
held in place by water paste we're not
carving or sculpting in that more
traditional sense you know we're growing
the image sort of develops over over the
period of weeks to grow one of our
pieces we grow the grass vertically then
we turn the whole of the studio space
here into a dark room
and so the only light that the grass
receives as it's growing is from the
projected negative image so where the
strongest light hits the grass it
produces more of the chlorophyll more of
a green pigment where there's less light
it's less green where there's no light
it grows but it's italiated and yellow
so you get the equivalent to a black and
white photograph but in terms of green
to yellow
portraits we tend to do around six foot
by four foot or maybe seven foot by five
foot in this case we can work really
really large scale and what's great
about that is that it's not it's not
sized in a gratuitous way actually the
resolution we get is really really
extraordinary it's phenomenal if you
equate a chlorophyll molecule with a
pixel then we're getting kind of like
many more pixels
for kind of like you know kind of like
square footage you can get on the large
ones is absolutely fantastic it's part
of a process of discovery you know as
artists you're looking to make
discoveries within the materials and
mediums that you work with and you know
light
and seeds um water
crystals all of those are kind of part
of our palette of materials that we play
with if water regularly and kept at low
light levels these grass portraits can
last indefinitely
there's something about seeing the way
that they grow and they used to
materialize in front of you really and
you don't really get to see them until
the the last moment really when when you
can put the lights up
[Music]
oh wow
grass me up
[Music]
i feel that this piece has got a real
strength
about it you know i think the person we
photographed in their youth
just has this real kind of connection
with the camera and he's somebody who
cares
passionately about what he's doing it's
like a watercolor color grazes through
it you know that's very very beautiful
still a bit taken aback by how it's
grass
i know i know
we're really really pleased with it
we're really pleased the way that it's
grown
[Music]